rachel good morning how can i help
good morning how are you i'm good i'm
good so what's going on
um so about almost three years ago um i
placed a little girl up for adoption
um it is an open adoption um
but i guess i'm i'm going through that
i'm kind of processing it now
to where i'm going through that i guess
you would say trauma
um and i don't really know how to get
through it yeah
because she's getting older she's
getting more of a personality and
becoming more of a
person to interact with huh yeah
we still talk like once a week um but
i mean i i just don't know how to how to
have those interactions without letting
her
i guess live her own life with her her
adoptive family
so paint me a picture of what that
struggle's like
um so we'll maybe have a call once a
week
um we'll we'll talk about how her day is
how she's doing with school
stuff like that um and then you know
she'll go about her day but then
whenever that that phone call ends i
kind of have this
i guess this disconnection and then this
kind of emptiness you know
and you know that's okay right
yeah i do i mean i'm real close to the
adoptive parents
um but are they doing a great job oh
they're doing an amazing job
amazing so how young were you when you
got pregnant
21 21 and what sets you on the path
to make the courageous decision to adopt
your baby
out oh i wasn't ready and i knew that
yeah absolutely not ready in this family
they had that i had i
placed their fort with um they had been
trying for over 10 years
so it was absolutely time and i knew
they were perfect
but i guess it's kind of just getting to
that point of i'm just
preparing myself for that question of
you know why didn't you want me
kind of thing yeah one thing i'd
recommend you do that would be a great
great gift to this baby and
not only this baby but this kid and not
only this kid but this young
woman and not only this young woman but
this future mother someday herself
is if you began to honor yourself and
honor her
by writing down your experiences and
keeping
really detailed journal notes for her
because one day you're right she's going
to come and say hey mom how come
and 10 years from now you're not going
to have as good an answer as you did
three years ago right but if you've got
a journal a serial
series right of i miss you
and i'm so grateful you're in the place
you're supposed to be
and your parents were incredible and i
wasn't ready
and one day she will recognize the
courageous gangster
awesome mother that you are in
that you knew enough to know that the
best thing for her was to give
her for give her to a great wonderful
family who had the
the scope and the means to raise her and
adopt open adoptions are beautiful and
they are really really hard
because these are uncharted waters right
we're not used to this
but i also want you to honor the fact
that you
know that you did the right thing and
this also sucks
and one thing that we don't do good as a
society is to live in this tension
of it's got to be either awful or really
great
and this is just a middle road right
where it's going to be this bittersweet
joy and excitement and also really hard
and really frustrating
do you have somebody in your life that
you can be open with
i do how do those conversations go
um it's normally with my sister she's
the one who who was there and read
read me the adoption papers that i
signed in the hospital
and that she she's been through
everything with me
but she she's open with them um
she actually talks to the adopted
parents too and
so we have really great communication
yeah they sound wonderful
so what's something that brings you joy
these days
um i mean it's probably talking to her
once a week
really that's probably it so i want you
to spend more time talking to her
on pen and paper or open up a word
document and just start writing
and one of the greatest gifts you will
give her one day is knowing that she's
not alone and she's not crazy
and that she will have a play-by-play of
how much her birth mother truly loved
her
she will have the connective experience
of
her adoptive family that raised her and
loved her
and there could be a moment here when
she's 18 19 20 21 when she gets to
just be showered by love that some of us
may never get to experience
she's going to have two moms that love
her more than life itself right
and also it may be come time when you
have to protect yourself
and if you're not healthy for her then
letting her know we're going to talk
every other week
or every other other yeah i think that i
think that's where i'm at because i
don't
i don't really know where that line is
between
i want you to be with your adoptive
family but i kind of want you to make
your own decision as to whether
i'm in your life or not right and for a
three-year-old that's not fair
because she's three yeah for a 10 year
old that's not fair
for a 21 year old that's fair
and so if you don't feel like you're in
a place where you can
honor that relationship and i say honor
it it's messy and it's hard but that you
can connect with her and she knows you
and it's
well but if you're doing it just to
fulfill you
that can be really hard on her
and so maybe practice see what it's like
to do every two weeks
see what it's like to do every three
weeks you're playing a marathon here so
if you miss a week you miss a week
right yeah and i don't want to
undermine or um that undermines the
wrong word i don't want to minimize
okay but i'll just tell you this
experience my wife is
an extraordinary scholar and researcher
and she was asked to come
work at a school for a few weeks in
brazil when my son was
i think he was three or maybe he was
four
and so i went with her and i brought him
and
my son and i were in sao paulo outside
of sao paulo brazil
and we had two weeks of just father-son
time and we were in the parks
and we were went to these weird places
where he got to
ride donkeys into the jungle and two
cans were like flying around
and we pulled mangoes and avocados off
of trees i mean it was extraordinary
it was a once in a lifetime trip me and
my son
in the jungle with meeting wonderful
people eating new foods
and he's 10 now and he remembers not one
second of that trip at all
none and so i tell you that to tell you
this
if you are working on your heart in this
deal
if you are working on i want to see if i
can go two weeks
i want to see if i can go a month
between these conversations i need to
begin to let go of the reins because i
feel
my grip is getting tighter and tighter
and that tight tight grip is going to
hurt
her she's going to know you loved her
she's going to be able to read that
journal you're going to be writing she's
going to
be loved by her adoptive family and
she's not going to remember that mom
missed a week once
or that mom went from every week to
every month
she's not gonna remember that
you will but she won't
yeah do you have any other kids
no i do not okay when you have your next
kid
one day it will be hard then too i think
instead of your sister or in addition to
your sister i think it'd be wise for you
rachel
to get a counselor just to talk through
it
because i think that the separation part
is going to be hard here especially as
you're 24 25
26 you're coming here into your own
you have full-time employment you meet
somebody
and you get a stable home you're it's
going to be harder and harder and i
think having somebody that will navigate
this not just as your sister she's great
good person to be vulnerable with
but having someone that can teach you
some skills on how to take care of
yourself your heart and mind in this
thing
i think that would be really awesome